hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD unboxing video in this video we're
going to be taking a look at the gateway
HX 2000 20 inch monitor this is a 20
inch 16 by 9 LCD is obviously the
sixteen by nine resolution because the
resolution is sixteen hundred by nine
hundred so today I'm just going to be
unboxing it and giving you guys a
general look at the hardware let's see
what comes in the box
give a look at the ports on the monitor
etc so here we go surround the top here
we have what looks like the stand or the
base to the monitor it's kind of a
glossy plastic if you ask me and this
will hook up to the monitor itself put
that to the side we have what we'll say
a little bit of paper this is something
about refurbished products and the
review units and stuff we have more
information about the product so here we
have what looks like a VGA cable let's
take this out yes this is a VGA cable so
this does come with the VGA and it has a
VGA port so I'll put that next to the
stand
and this here sorry this is a VGA and
power cable so this this over here is
going to be your DVI and this is going
to be VGA and power so it obviously does
have inputs for both VGA and DVI so now
for the slightly more difficult task of
between a monitor out
so obviously the monitor is it's a lot
larger than the monitor I'm boxed a
little bit earlier which was the HP W
1707 monitor it's gonna take it right
out of the plastic here so here's the
LCD itself it's obviously very glossy so
we're going to get reflections with it
I'm gonna go ahead and put it on the
stand and see what kind of what it looks
like with the stand so here's the glossy
stand this is what it looks like has
some kind of mechanism here I'm just
going to show you guys what it looks
like it's tempting to put it on the
stand so that was relatively simple it
did have a little bit of a click when I
got it in so this is what the monitor
looks like does have a little bit of a
tilt as you can tell I'll go ahead and
move you guys up here has a little bit
of a tilt so if we move this forward we
can move it back on the bottom front of
the monitor it's kind of hard to tell
but do you have your auto button your
menu button your left right and your
volume adjustment buttons here's the
bottom of the monitor and you can see on
the right hand side your DVI and your
VGA connectors and on the left hand side
with the built-in speakers you have your
audio your audio jack and your power
jack so overall it's a good sized 20
inch monitor this is the gateway on the
left and I have it next to a comparable
glossy monitor which is the HP W 1707
that iron box so you can see it does
look nice they are both glossy they both
are the sort of piano black and have a
nice glossy finish which I do like for
the color vibrancy that it provides
here's the thickness for you guys with
the two monitors again with the Gateway
being a one on the left it is a little
bit thicker and a little bit more
rounded and it is also all black on the
back and I like the fact that this
monitor is completely black but I do
like that this monitor is also quite
thin for an LCD so thanks for watching
this unboxing and overview of the
gateway HX 2020 inch monitor again with
the 5 millisecond response time 1600 by
900 resolution and ten thousand to one
dynamic contrast ratio so I'll give you
guys probably
of this monitor if you decide so go
ahead and leave your comments about that
until then this is mkbhd and thank you
very much for watching talk to you guys
later peace